victoria para emmanuel macro pero es
probable que las celebraciones duren
poco sus oponentes políticos ya se están
alineando para la próxima batalla
electoral las elecciones legislativas en
junio ese voto definirá la composición
del gobierno en el que confiara para
impulsar sus políticas con el apoyo de
aliados centristas el partido república
en marcha del presidente tiene una clara
mayoría en el parlamento saliente en el
extremo izquierdo francia insumisa tiene
sólo 17 diputados mientras que
agrupación nacional de marine le pen
tiene 8 los presidentes recién elegidos
suelen obtener una mayoría en la
asamblea nacional debido a la baja
participación general entre los
partidarios de los candidatos derrotados
pero una desafiante marín gp me está
instando a los votantes a asegurarse de
que haya un fuerte bloque de oposición
no los lanzamos esta noche la gran
batalla electoral de las legislativas
lideraré esta batalla con todos aquellos
que tuvieron el coraje de oponerse a
manuel macrón después de perder por poco
en la votación de la primera ronda el
veterano de extrema izquierda de luc
mélenchon tienen los ojos puestos en un
nuevo objetivo fluctuación tú
como la tercera ronda comienza a esta
noche entre los días 12 y 19 de junio al
pedirles que me elijan como su primer
ministro de hecho les estoy pidiendo que
creen un nuevo futuro para nuestro
pueblo
los votantes también parecen ansiosos
por el cambio una nueva encuesta sugiere
que sólo uno de cada cinco quiere que
makro obtenga la mayoría con más de la
mitad a favor de una alianza que
bloquearía sus políticas a pesar de
tener el impulso detrás de ella le pen
se sintió amargamente decepcionada en
las elecciones regionales de junio
pasado cuando su partido no logró
quedarse con ninguna de las regiones
misión también ha tenido problemas para
ganar terreno a nivel local sobre los
verdes y los socialistas que ganaron
varias ciudades importantes incluidas
parís marsella y burdeos en las
elecciones municipales del 2020